Okay, so let's get right back into it because
it's been a very busy a news weekend.
Devin Nunez, Republican Congressman from California,
as I told you earlier, has now been implicated
in the Ukraine fiasco, Republican Congressman
Devin Nunez, the same guy who was running
to the white house to talk to Trump while
he was running the house intelligence committee
investigation of Donald Trump, the same guy
who was asking the questions during the last
two weeks of Trump impeachment inquiry hearings
is now accused of meeting with Ukrainian officials
and being one of those people looking for
dirt on Joe Biden.
And we have travel records that corroborate
at least the timing of these allegations.
And Devin Nunez appeared on Fox business channel
yesterday and he was interviewed by Maria
Bartiromo.
Now understand Maria Bartiromo used to be
sort of inoffensive financial journalist on
CNBC.
When I was growing up, uh, I was a teenager.
I was starting to get into understanding stocks
and markets and so on and so forth.
And she has become one of the biggest sycophantic
Trump Brown nosing journalists in the ecosystem
over the last few years of the Trump era,
she interviewed Devin Nunez and asked him
straight up, Devin, is this true?
Did you go to Vienna?
Uh, like Rudy Giuliani's, henchmen loved Parness
alleges and meet with Victor Shoken and Devin
Nunez.
Not only doesn't answer, he doesn't answer
in the most absurd way possible, which to
us is completely transparent as a lie.
But unfortunately, because he invokes the
idea of fake news, CNN, this probably will
be pleasurable to many Trumpists who have
been conditioned by the meme of fake news.
He says, you know, I can't talk about that
because the allegations that I did this are
criminal implicating CNN.
Take a look at this video.
Where are you in Vienna with Shogun?
Yeah.
So look, Maria, uh, I really want to answer
all of these questions, uh, and I promise
you absolutely.
We'll come back on the show and answer these
questions.
But because there is criminal activity here,
we're working with the appropriate law enforcement
agencies.
We're going to file all this.
Everyone's gonna know the truth.
Everybody's going to know all the facts.
But I, you can understand that I can't compete
by trying to, trying to debate this out with
the public media when 90% of the media are
totally corrupt.
And because this is criminal in nature and
because it's so bad, it's so slanderous.
Uh, we've got all the facts on our side and
we're going to file in federal court, uh,
because I'm not gonna sit here and try to
compete against the media that I have no chance
of winning.
I will win in court and they'll have a chance
to cooperate.
And, uh, they'll have to do to show how they
work with somebody who's been indicted, uh,
which is, you know, likely, uh, conspiring
to obstruct justice.
So, so I want to just be clear before I move
on to, I ain't going to get your take on the
impeachment hearings, but, but just to be
clear, you're saying you're suing CNN, you're
going to Sue daily beast.
You, you, I know you've sued Twitter in the
past.
Do you think this is going somewhere?
You're telling me that CNN committed criminal
activity?
Well, it's, it's very likely.
All you need to know is that you didn't hear
a no.
You didn't hear Devin Nunez say, now I wasn't
in Vienna meeting with Victor Shoken.
That was nowhere in there and that's what
you call yes, he was there.
He will say it was for some other reason.
Eventually when it can no longer be denied
that he was there, he's pretending that he
simply can't compete with the media narrative
that is against him as he claims to be.
The reality is it's obviously true.
It already has been corroborated at least
circumstantially by the financial records
of his travel, uh, to Europe at the time in
question.
Simply say you weren't there if you weren't
there.
The idea that CNN is criminal here is of course
it's a red herring.
It's a complete misdirection, but it's sadly
a misdirection that will probably be effective
on a lot of Trumpists who have been swayed
by the supposed CNN is fake news narrative.
Devin Nunez got caught and now all he can
do is pretend he can't talk about it because
he's suing this person and he's suing that
organization.
And this could all end up really going backwards
for Devin Nunez because as I've already told
you, there are congressional travel records
that corroborate this.
He appears to have done this on your dollars
on taxpayer dollars.
There are recordings of Trump and Giuliani
where for all we know this was discussed,
which Lev Parness has provided to the house
intelligence committee.
Where we are headed is that Adam Smith, not
Adam shifts shift runs the house intelligence
committee.
Smith runs the house armed services committee.
It's a different Congressman.
Adam Smith says that Nunez probably has another
ethics probe coming against him.
He was already the subject of an ethics probe
in 2017 were you in Vienna with Victor Shogun?
I want to answer these questions and someday
I will come back and do it after endless frivolous
lawsuits and work their way through the system.
And you've long forgotten about my involvement
in this.
That is effectively what he is saying.
Uh, and, and by the way, Maria Bartiromo,
the interviewer, again, a total Trump Brown
noser she pretends that this answer makes
sense.
It seems like she's actually going to ask
a question to try to just get a straight factual
statement declaration from Devin Nunez.
Bottom line, were you in Vienna with Victor
Shoken and then Devin Nunez launches into
this.
I'm the victim.
I'm a martyr.
Everybody's after me.
It's all illegal.
It's all criminal.
What's been done to me by even suggesting
this and Maria Bartiromo plays a long thing,
right?
Right.
He says, you know, I can't fight the narrative
that's coming at me from all sides.
Ride of course.
Devon, of course, this is a page straight
out of Trump's playbook.
I will release my taxes once irrelevant and
possibly non-existent.
Audits are completed.
Well, but Donald Trump, are you under audit
for every year?
There must be some recent years you're not
currently being audited for.
Right.
What about releasing some of those?
I'm under audit.
Once it's done, I'll release the taxes.
Never happened, of course.
And then I'll have some new reason because
it's political.
The seeking of my taxes is political or whatever
else.
I have new details about Barack Obama's birth
certificate, which I will share whenever.
Doesn't happen.
The entire thing was a hoax.
The birth or fiasco was a race based, a hit
job done by some really ugly elements of the
American.
Right.
With the help of then reality show host, Donald
Trump, whatever.
This is not what an innocent person sounds
like and eventually they are, you know what
the transition will be.
We've seen it with everything.
It'll go from it never happened to, okay,
Devin Nunez was in Vienna and sure he met
with Victor Shoken but that's not a crime.
He wanted corruption to be investigated in
Ukraine and of course that continues to be
a meme that they rest on.
But why aren't we asking if you crane is as
corrupt as Trump and everybody says they are,
why would you go to them and ask them to investigate?
Corruption doesn't really make any sense.
Why would you go to a burglar and say, I need
you above anyone else to investigate burglary.
You wouldn't do it.
It doesn't make any sense.
And from the beginning we knew that and it's
only becoming increasingly transparent now.
So we'll see when they shift to a shift from,
I didn't do it to, I did it, but there's nothing
wrong with that.
That's just called politics.